Oprah was a guest on your show yeah how
long ago and realize you've known her 20
years she's actually sort of how you got
into this side of the business right not
sorta yeah I mean that's the way in if
you're gonna get in go with the big oh
right yeah I'm just here to love you
softballs you do whatever you wanna do I
did nothing they were the ones that went
with that your minds out of the gutter
yeah so yeah Oprah Winfrey sort of had
tell us the story how did this happen it
was 20 years ago
yeah it's 20 years ago I was helping
defend her in the Mad Cow case in
Amarillo when she was getting sued for
by the beef folks right you remember she
made a comment about beef and they sued
her in Amarillo and she had to go up
there and testify fight them off they're
there sooner four billion dollars up
there and so I was a trial consultant
one of your ex one of your areas of
expertise is a trial consultant was
being able to spot lies when someone's
lying yes do you lie a lot I do not what
do you think I think you're full of [ __ ]
you see people with people lied they
have tails well let's learn what those
are well like when you lie your hair
goes
[Laughter]
over here did you tell when people do
you think you can tell when people lie I
I don't think I can no I don't think I
don't think I'm that good at knowing if
someone's lying or not but I'm
surrounded by sociopaths you know I
don't know everyone that works for me is
a monster
sociopaths are sociopaths are pretty
good at it but they all have tails and
if you're talking to somebody and they
there are some things that are obvious
they get nervous they put their hand up
to cover their mouth because part of
them doesn't want you to look at them if
they touch their nose or their photos is
any indication that someone's lying yeah
it's it's either that they have a cold
or they're touching their nose it's that
they're lying and a lot of things they
say if somebody you're talking to
somebody and they say all right to tell
you the truth or honestly what does that
mean everything you've been saying was a
lie right and now I'm gonna tell you the
truth they feel it they feel the need to
actually go out of their way to tell you
that emphasize this if they tell you all
right Conan honestly whatever they're
getting ready to say is a damn lie okay
if they say I swear to God
really we're going to invoke the deity
that's how badly you need help to get me
to believe this you're gonna invoke the
deity whatever they're getting ready to
say is most likely a lie okay and so if
they're doing those sort of things where
they just feel the need to just bring in
everything they can to support what
they're getting ready to tell you pretty
good chance it's a lie all right that's
useful to know in everyday life yeah hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography